this is the scene in Nottingham this
evening and it is uh Old Market Square
and it is packed and the Lord mayor of
Nottingham is speaking so let's just
have a listen
it's a very sad week for
the event day we're a tragedy and so it
is important that we all come together
and support each other at this difficult
time
we have lots of people who would like to
say a few words and to pay their
respects
can I start by inviting the leader of
the council David Mellon to this stage
thank you
good evening
thank you for Gathering here in the
middle of Nottingham
it is important that we stand shoulder
to shoulder as we respond to the
shocking violence witness in our streets
this week
we stand with the families and friends
of two of our students
Grace and Barnaby
who've had their lives cut short at a
time when they should have been
celebrating the completion of their
first year of studies at Nottingham
museum University
we also stand with the family and
colleagues of one of our public servants
Ian
who's also lost his life after many
years of several serving several schools
in our city as their site manager
we also stand with those who were
injured in the city center early on
Tuesday Morning who are being treated in
hospital and with those
who are caring for them
we stand with our education community
one of our universities and one of our
schools who are in Shock after this
attack on students and a member of staff
to you I say this
the attack on you is an attack on us all
we stand with colleagues in the police
and the Emergency Services who responded
so swiftly on that terrible morning
and who now continue with the ongoing
investigation
we stand with those in our transport
services
with Council staff doing so many
different roles seen and unseen
and for those who are providing support
and reassurance to our City Community at
this difficult time
and as the cameras of our country's
media channels are focused on our city
this week
as the leader of the council here
I want to thank you the people of
Nottingham for your support and
solidarity this week
from those who early on Tuesday morning
didn't cross the road
didn't avoid the situation
but ran to the support of those who
would shockingly been mowed down
tending to their needs
and to those who have offered comfort
and support
sometimes with no words
because there are few words to say at a
time like this
for those of you who have cared and
shared the grief of our communities this
week I thank you
it is fitting That We Gather today to
share our sadness and our loss
and to remember the three people who
died
as with all tragic events we can choose
to express our grief individually in our
own way or we can join together
collectively to share that burden
it is right that we have the opportunity
to be together
at this difficult time
and as the lead of the council I'm here
to say you do not carry this burden
alone
I'm grateful that we have members of the
British Red Cross and Salvation Army
here in the crowd who are available to
talk to anyone who struggled to process
these awful events
and as Grace's father said so movingly
yesterday
we all need to look out for each other
and look after each other at this time
Nottingham is a great City and a city
where the events that we have seen this
week shock us
because they are so unusual they are not
in our ordinary experience
we have a city that is safe and
welcoming where people can go about
their business without fear on a
day-to-day basis and we must not allow
fear to grip our streets and be the
dominant emotion here
I'm grateful to our partners who've
stood together for Nottingham many of
you are here tonight and we'll hear from
some of you in a moment I'm grateful to
our faith leaders for not only being
here but also for opening your buildings
to those who are mourning this week and
for leading us in our prayers in
Nottingham this week has been awful for
those of you who have lost loved ones it
will of course take time to come to
terms with your loss if it ever is
possible to get over something so
terrible but we stand together with you
thank you Nottingham for coming together
this evening
let's continue to care for each other in
the days to come thank you
[Applause]
I'll Now call upon Ross Middleton head
teacher of Huntington Academy thank you
Ross good evening everybody
Ian was the site manager our sign
manager at Huntington Academy in Saint
Anne's a community the team and I are
proud to serve
we had worked with Ian for seven years
and like in any place of work had been
through births deaths
weddings and of course the covid
pandemic where Ian played a crucial role
in keeping our children and colleagues
safe thank you Ian
Ian looked after people
assisting in any way possible and always
put the Children First
I'll never forget how excited he was
putting plans together and then creating
his show-stopping Christmas displays
which never failed to wow and impress
everybody that saw them
in recent weeks he had helped year three
with their sewing projects and created
castles for the children's reading
Corners to make them even more engaging
he was full of fun with the mischievous
glint in his eye
particularly when joining in with the
year six some awards fight
his time commitment and Care in nature
endeared him to the whole school
community and we all will all remember
him with great affection
my abiding memory of Ian will be the
great deal of time he spent with his
beloved grandson
and how he looked at his grandson with
such love and pride
Ian you did a great job there
rest in peace Ian and of course I'll
keep an eye out on Forest results for
you
thank you
[Applause]
can I now call upon Professor Shira West
together with the Reverend Grant Walton
chaplain of University and vice Charter
University
thank you very much Mel
Lord mayor councilor Mellon people of
Nottingham
thank you everybody for attending this
important vigil for communities across
the city
today we were together United in our
shock and our grief
to remember all those who've lost their
lives or were injured in Tuesday's
attacks
it remains hard to find words to express
the sadness and bewilderment felt across
our city and Far Beyond at the senseless
loss of lives
Ross has just told us about Ian Coates
who is a devoted father and grandfather
and a respected member of the caretaking
staff at Huntington Academy
four months from retirement he was an
avid fisherman who used his sport to
divert underprivileged young people away
from crime
Grace O'Malley Kumar was a medical
student thriving in her first year of
study and inspired to a career in
medicine through her volunteering for
the vaccination program during the
covert pandemic
she was a talented sportswoman playing
hockey and Cricket at National level
Barney Weber was a history student where
his tutors recall his energy he was fun
he was friendly he was full of life
in his seminars and he too excelled in
sport as well as studies playing hockey
rugby and Cricket for his school and
local clubs
all three of these lives were cut short
in the most unimaginable way on Tuesday
Morning their well-earned retirement
plans and Bright Futures brutally
curtailed at by a seemingly random act
of violence
at the University we held our own vigil
yesterday with Barney and Grace's
families to remember them and mourn
their loss
I was overwhelmed by the love and
support that was offered to the families
by more than 2 000 students and staff
that had gathered together as a
community
although seemingly unconnected to these
Dreadful acts we are still in the
University trying to process the
information that the suspect in custody
was a former student
today I stand here as the leader of a
university which is immensely proud to
be part of the city we call home
today I stand together with our students
and staff in support of everyone
affected by this tragedy
and today I stand with all communities
in Nottingham in defiance of the
senseless act of violence
against this backdrop of the deepness
sadness and lost the deepest sad sadness
and loss
I hope in time we can draw some comfort
from the thousands of messages of
support and condolences received locally
nationally and globally in response to
this Dreadful tragedy
the people of Nottingham know that this
is not what our city is about
and we will not let this single
horrifying event Define who we are and
what we stand for
our communities are united in grief but
we will draw upon the enormous strength
of every one of us as Citizens and our
pride in our city as we come together to
recover and start the long journey to
heal
I'd like to hand over now to our
chaplain Grant who will also say a few
words thank you
thank you Shira and good evening
everybody
since I had the privilege of relocating
to Nottingham myself a little over five
years ago I have encountered
numerous people who have told me the
same thing
they came here as students or on work
contracts
and they loved the city so much
they decided to come back and settle
permanently
I've also spoken to many current
University of Nottingham students who
tell me
that their desire is to remain in
Nottingham
once they graduate
this is a place of vibrant communities
of hopefulness and faith
it's a place where people stand together
to confront challenges to grow stronger
through them
it's a place that we are privileged to
enjoy the energetic liveliness that
accommodating so many young people
brings
but there is no doubt
that the horrific events of the last two
days will have changed us
both as individuals and collectively
in ways that we have yet to discover
we most certainly do not anticipate
waking up one bright Tuesday morning
to be confronted with the traumatic
violent and needless loss
of two of our students Grace and Barney
of a wonderful community-minded man Ian
coats
and of the serious injury of innocent
people on their way to work
our hearts and prayers reach out to the
families and friends of those who are
mourning and coping with the devastation
and although we should not be quick to
gloss over the implications of all of
this for our city and its communities
right now we must grieve
and express our shock honestly and
openly with all its range of emotions
thoughts and feelings we must talk about
those we have lost and verbalize our
reactions to one another
but the time will come when we must also
do the difficult work
of sorting through the aftermath
so that we ourselves
and our city
may continue to become the kind of
people and place that we want to be
on behalf of all the chaplains at the
University of Nottingham may I express
our commitment
to walk this journey ahead with students
University staff and all the members of
our wider community
thank you
[Applause]
can I now call upon Alex Norris MP
good evening everybody my name is Alex
Norris I'm Member of Parliament for the
north of the city I speak on behalf of
my colleagues Lillian Greenwood and
Nadia Whitson we are united in our grief
our sadness and our shock at what we've
seen this week we like everyone I think
here not used to waking up to see such
devastating news about our city the
place we all love so much leading the
news for all the wrong reasons and to
see the loss of three much-loved members
of our community who in their own ways
made such an impact and an impression
and our thoughts
are with those who've lost their lives
our thoughts are with their families and
our support for them in their
challenging days weeks months and years
ahead we must all be there for them and
our thoughts with those who are injured
and we hope for their swiftest recovery
um I want to say a few words on behalf
of the community of bulwell three and
coats
um it's seen in recent days if any of
you are from the north of the city I
suspect there's quite a few of you that
everybody seems to have a story from
their time at ball Academy or river lean
school about a way in which Ian touched
their lives and over those years those
thousands of lives touched whether it
was children locked in toilets whether
it was footballs taken down off roofs
even for a member of the council he got
that happened multiple times I've been
told whether whether it was in this I
found particularly poignant multiple
young men who said they were really
struggling at school who said that they
felt that school wasn't understanding
them who said that they weren't finding
their place in the world and that Ian
took the time to speak to them to be
honest with them
but to be kind and to listen to them and
to help them make their way through
their school life and their life more
generally what an extraordinary gift to
the world that is and then of course as
we've heard to many of those young
people passing on his love of fishing
giving up his own time his own money so
that he could pass that love onto others
and give them that wonderful Outlet what
you know an incredible impression he's
made on our city and one that will not
be forgotten
and what we've seen is senseless and
we're trying to make sense seems so hard
but Ian's life is the opposite of that
his was selfless it was full of love
love for his family love for his
football team well represented here
today love for his community love for
those who needed it and that spirit is
one that we must take forwards from
today and what I look over is an
extraordinary scene you know we're only
ever all together like this in Market
Square generally when it's good news
something good in sport or in music and
it's terrible to think that this has
brought us together in this way United
in grief but I hope that that gives a
little bit of Hope for all of us for the
future because what comes in the days
weeks and months ahead is going to be
very very difficult and we aren't going
to need each other the families are
going to need our support
so
love with love always wins sometimes it
feels like that might not be the case
but love always wins
and we'll deal with this as we deal with
everything Nottingham together thank you
thank you
uh ladies and gentlemen Caroline Henry
our police and crime commissioner thank
you
our wonderful City
has been shocked by this tragic incident
and our thoughts are with the loved ones
of those who've been killed Barnaby
Grace and Ian
it's also affected a number of people
who were injured or who witnessed these
horrific attacks
help and support is available for them
all through Nottinghamshire police and
the Nottinghamshire victim care service
Nottingham is world renowned for its
welcoming friendly and warm people
lots of people come here and fall in
love with our city
it's a vibrant Social Scene two
world-class universities that attract
people from all around the globe to come
here to Nottingham
it was particularly poignant when I
attended Atlanta Station of University
students on Tuesday night this week
it was at our headquarters
seven budding volunteer special police
constables pledged to join and serve
Nottinghamshire police
and actually they couldn't wait to join
our Force and to serve the public in
coming days
it's really important at times like this
we come together as a city
and the vigils held across Nottingham
showed up Community is United
I was at the vigil last night at
University of Nottingham
where the fathers of born at Barnaby and
Grace who I can see today
gave the most moving speeches about how
much their children love Nottingham
an appeal to everybody to show love
and to look out for each other
[Music]
although there were thousands of people
present last night
and actually like tonight
everyone just stood silent
you could hear a pin drop
last night the only noise that
punctuated The Sound of Silence was a
police siren sounding in the distance as
our hard-working professional police
team
still continue to deliver their
round-the-clark public service to keep
people safe
at times like this you can't fail to
recognize the incredible work of our
Emergency Services who were always there
for us in our hour of need
my message to the public now
is to have faith in our fantastic
Nottinghamshire police force and remain
patient as they tirelessly work to
investigate the incident through the
criminal justice process
we've talked a lot about love tonight
it's so important
there is no place for hate
in the healing process
it's important that remain United and
come back stronger
from this tragedy as Nottingham together
Thank You Caroline
in a minute we're going to have a moment
of silence
will start that silence when the the
clock behind us sounds for six o'clock
and after the sixth ring for the hour we
will be silent for a minute
we've got a few minutes yet
before that
you might be standing with loved ones
you might be standing with people you
don't know at all
and I just want you just for a couple of
minutes just to say hello
to the people around you to wish them
well
to join together as we mourn this awful
tragedy this week and then when the
clock starts to sound if we can then
regain some peace and some quiet ready
for that when it's silence
thank you very much
so this is another vigil taking place in
the city of Nottingham another vigil in
the sunshine but these truly are dark
days for this city Grim days for this
city after those events of Tuesday this
is the City Center Old Market Square as
you can see hundreds of people gathered
again the council leader said We join
together to share
uh this burden you do not shoulder this
burden alone and then he spoke about
Nottingham uh which he called a
a great city
um these events shock us he said because
they are so unusual in this city
and then he said we must not allow fear
to grip our streets
and uh we heard from the head teacher of
the academy Huntington Academy where Ian
Coates who also was killed was caretaker
and the head teacher said that Ian
looked after people and always looked
after the children first we all remember
him with great affection and he said his
fondest memory of his of him was him
with his grandchild he said who uh he
deeply loved and then we heard from the
vice Chancellor of the University where
a vigil took place
last night and she spoke about the two
students who were killed Grace O'Malley
Kumar thriving as a medical student she
said
uh and a talented sportswoman and
Barnaby Weber history student
and also excelling in sports and she
said we will not let these events Define
who we are or Define this city
well our reporter Becky Cottrell is with
me
um
who's just told me she was born in the
city of Nottingham and Becky this really
is a city coming together
and spiritually you know at the center
of the city it's famed for its Stone
lines you can't see them now because of
all the people there but this is
certainly a Fitting Place to hold a
video like this and you can see how many
people have turned out clearly wanting
to come and be together at this time
and then you heard the leader of the
council say just then that before the
minute silence he wants people in the
Square to just turn to the people next
to them and reflect on what's happened
and kind of share the sense of of
community because they need to hold on
to it right now we've heard a lot said
about you know this violence does not
represent Nottingham and I think that
that's what this is about really you
know a lot of these people will not ever
have met the victims but
they'll be mourning their loss and also
feeling potentially quite fearful about
what's happened and they'll just want to
come together and remember that there is
a lot of humanity in this place too
and a lot of students at the vigil
obviously at the University last night a
lot of students it seems here as well
and I spoke to the MP when I was up in
Nottingham on Tuesday and she said
students are the heart and soul of of
this city yeah definitely I mean a lot
of students because obviously there are
two big universities in Nottingham and
people do stay on there my own mother
stayed on after studying in Nottingham
and you know the students won't
necessarily have families there of
course because they've moved to the area
so for them the student Community is
their community and I'm sure they'll
want to be together right now
[Music]
Becky thank you very much
for the moment and the bells are
sounding in Nottingham City Center and
they're preparing for uh
about to take place
right now
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
thank you everyone I'm now going to
invite representatives of Nottingham's
Faith communities to come forward onto
the stage and to each say a few words in
turn I'm inviting Pastor Dr Ezekiel
aliwale
from the majority black LED churches I'm
inviting gertrand manku from the Sikh
community in Nottingham
Rajesh Sharma the Hindu community in
Nottingham
shaduate Aslam chair of the Nottingham
Council of mosques
Rabbi jili zidi Kayu Nottingham liberal
synagogue
the right Reverend Patrick McKinney the
Catholic bishop of Nottingham and the
right Reverend Paul Williams
the bishop of civil and Nottingham for
the Anglican community
ladies and gentlemen
they're not them Nottingham majority
black churches wish to express our
deepest condolences
and sympathies
to their families and friends of the
three victims of the Orlando's and
tragic attack
in our city of Nottingham
it is unimaginable
the pain and the grief
that the families
of the young students
at
who had so much to live for
and our dear caretaker
who was simply doing his job for our
community must be going through
our prayers are with you all
may the Lord Comfort all living hearts
we know that Nottingham is a tolerance
welcoming friendly and peaceful City
so this attack
is even even more shocking
and we fully condemn evil Acts
of violence
we also take a moment to acknowledge the
hard work the dedication of
Nottinghamshire purpose
we've been working tirelessly
together to ensure safety security of
our community
we are grateful for their promptness
bravery
and commitment in keeping them as a
belief
the majority black LED churches
pledge our commitment
to work together
with the police to the community of such
evil hacks
together
we will overcome this difficult times
and make them a favor for all
with all people of Good Will and pray
for the healing and unity of our city
Nottingham
we are here to stand together with each
other
during this third time
we call for everyone
whatever our background
to stand together in this moment and
grief
as the Nottingham majority black
churches we pray that the light of love
peace and healing will be it foremost in
our hearts our minds to ensure
that nothing like this
will fall on our city again
may God bless us all
right
foreign
good evening everyone I'm kacharan Singh
manku I'm a trustee at one of the seven
gurdwaras places of worship in
Nottingham
it is truly incomprehensible
that this great City
many of us call home
has lost
three wonderful people
in such a devastating and horrible way
Barnaby Weber
Grace
emali Kumar and he encotes
was simply going about
their daily business
when their lives were taken
it is sad
so sad
that one person can make such a
devastating impact on so many lives
from all seven goodwillers
and the Sikh community of Nottingham
we reach out with our thoughts and
prayers to the family and friends
of all those affected
by the events
on Tuesday
Barnaby Grace and Ian especially
this is our city
a great City and we thank and commend
wonderful people
all of you are here today
doing the right in supporting all of the
affected the events
Tuesday morning
thank you good evening
[Applause]
namaste
um
[Music]
um is a universal word that resonates
and connects one with your inner self
and with the universe
at this difficult time chanting
um will hopefully bring inner peace to
those suffering
Henderson also teaches us that
our way of life by following certain
principles and following them
one of the principles is that that is
inevitable it is all good it is going to
all of us one day and we must be
prepared for it
may bring some comfort to the families
and friends of The Departed Souls that
Lord Shiva will give moksh and a board
in his kingdom to Grace Barnaby and Ian
and also to the family of the deported
Souls the almighty may he give them
strength to cope with the precious
losses
at this time as it's been Stand United
Hinduism says we are one Community We
Are One humankind on this Earth
we must live as a harmonious community
so in a moment I'm going to ask you to
be enchantingham but just before that
may I please ask each of you
positively to give the Positive Vibes
and positive messages to the families of
the dear Departed
so and the community of Nottingham that
we get through this difficult period
also I would like you in unity to hand
hold hands if you wish with the person
next to you I'll give you a moment to do
that then I will ask you to join me in
chanting home for as long as you can so
okay
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
so on on behalf of the Nottingham Muslim
Community and I offer my deepest and
sincerest sorrow at your untimely tragic
and unimaginable loss that you must be
going through
it's at times like this at death a
bereavement you realize no one talks
about what was the house of the deceased
person what car did they drive these
things don't matter all that matters was
their values their behaviors their
interaction with each other and the
impact they had on the lives of many
others and when you look at the so many
positive things that have been written
about the deceased individuals you get
an amazing picture of individuals that
were giving that were caring and that's
really what matters and this is really
what stays this is their legacy their
impacts on students on Sports societies
on school kids where do you stop if I
was to pick out one one thing that stuck
out in my mind of a behavior or an
action or input what would stick out
what would your takeaway be for me it
was where I think Ian's son mentioned
that Dad was an avid fisherman and he
would take disadvantaged kids with him
fishing I mean that says so much about a
person doesn't it to keep them away from
a life of crime he cared for those kids
and those kids will always have memory
and love for that individual so a
murderer may have been able to take away
the lives of three individuals but he
can never take away the love and the
memories that stays in the hearts of the
loved ones and all of us today because
values of goodness and kindness will
always Prevail will always Prevail it
always has done it always will do
what else if I was to just end what else
do you take away from these individuals
was their profound love for Nottingham
it was so touching yesterday to hear the
appearance of Grace and body be
describing had the kids didn't want to
leave Nottingham and they heard so much
as a parent whose kids go to university
as well that we weren't able to look
after their kids as our kids are looked
after that hurts so much as parents they
sent their kids here and unfortunately
we weren't able to look after them but
it was their love for Nottingham Ian was
described as a lifelong Nottingham
Forest football fan their love of
Nottingham resonates so how do we honor
their memory and their Legacy by being
the best version of ourselves each day
today and every day in our behaviors in
our interactions in our impact and in
our community we show everyone we show
the world
truly is one Nottingham we come together
as one Community caring compassionate
hurt but together feeling that immense
immense loss of our beloved three
individuals that have lost sadly lost
their lives thank you
[Applause]
shalom
I am Rabbi Gilly from Nottingham liberal
synagogue I would like to share with the
words of Rabbi Sheila Shulman
we recognize that each of us is not so
much a person as a world or rather
Bearer in her
Overworld
a unique Irreplaceable populated World
linked by admired threats to other such
worlds
and that if when someone dies who has
been a part of our life
there is a rent in the universe like a
star Vanishing
but that like a star Vanishing that
world lives inner ineradicable to races
in us as a star does in space
so that we mourn but we remember
and we know that there will be a living
trace of that person in our
Consciousness always
let us remember the people we have lost
and let us remember the unique
Irreplaceable worlds that we all are
[Applause]
many things are possible for the person
who has hope
even more is possible for the person who
has faith
and still more is possible for the
person who knows how to love
but everything is possible for the
person who practices all three virtues
Pope Francis has spoken of the essential
that Hope plays in all our lives
he says that while hope is a silent and
a humble virtue it is that that supports
Us in times of difficulty such as these
brings us
I bring the prayers of the Catholic
Community particularly to the families
who have lost their lives
and with these words from Saint Paul's
letter to the Romans
as encouragement to them but as
encouragement to all of us here in this
city of Nottingham
let love be genuine
hate what is evil
hold fast to what is good
love one another
outdo one another in showing respect
rejoice
be patient in suffering
persevere in prayer
contribute to the needs of each other
and extend Hospitality to The Stranger
in spite of the horrific events that
have greatly affected the people of our
city
let us ask God this evening and in the
days to come for the spiritual help we
will need to be once again people of
deep hope thank you
foreign
Paul I'm the Church of England Bishop
for Sutherland Nottingham for this great
City and along with Bishop Patrick on
behalf of many Christian churches of
other denominations all across this city
things directly
changed for this city and especially for
the lives of those who were so cruelly
bereaved as a consequence of
unfolding in the early hours of Tuesday
morning
and this is a quite extraordinary sight
but it is what this city does
it comes together
and we stand together today on an
occasion where we would of course far
rather not have had
a reason to be here not a reason like
this
and I'm sure that that is felt more
deeply and intensely than we could
possibly imagine for those family
members and Friends
who come together with us today
to grieve
and to grieve
and even after the shock
and the outpouring of grief these past
two days
we need to say that Nottingham is not
about to Simply move on
and in one sense we never will
but we are moving in
pressing in to whole other mostly to
strengthen bonds of love
to keep stepping over invisible barriers
that sometimes may threaten to divide us
moving in to comfort those
whose grief is too heavy to ever bear
alone
and as Nottingham
standing together today we say
to the family and friends of Grace
Somali Kumar
Barnaby Weber
and coats
we will not forgive you
this city will not forget you
and we will never cease to pray for you
as churches across Nottingham
we're very thankful to play our part in
this extraordinary creative and deeply
compassionate City we do so in moments
of Triumph
and we do so in times of unbelievable
tragedy
as we have done this week
and I've been deeply moved to spend
most of the last three days at Saint
Peter's just a short distance from here
as hundreds of people of all ages have
come into that building to pray to weep
to light a candle people of all faiths
and nonsense has been the case in
churches all around the city here
and so
may God strengthen the hearts
that are so very broken
and may Christ Jesus bring healing
to our city
Come Holy Spirit
and I close with the ancient words that
have often been prayed over the
centuries in this city
prayer for us all
tonight keep watch dear Lord with those
who work
or watch or weep this night
give your angels charge over those who
sleep
tend the sick Lord Christ give rest to
the weary bless the dying soothe the
suffering pity The Afflicted
Shield the joyous
and all for your love's sake
and may that love
now continue to grow as we stand
together in this city
thank you
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen we're now going to
hear from members of the family of the
people that we have lost
and first of all we're going to Ian's
family
[Applause]
support to the family of wannabe
um
station we never thought we'd feel and
obviously they're going through the same
thing that we are anything they need
from us we're happy to support you need
I also want to thank everybody that's
given the kind words about my dad to
have a social media over the news in
person and it feels like he's touched a
lot of Hearts over the years more than
what we assumed and knew that he had so
it's been really nice and heartwarming
to see the messages and the people come
out and talk about how I was when they
were younger and how he's helped them
um some beautiful comments
um
we just wanted to say a quick thing that
we're still dealing with what's happened
we still haven't took it all in and so
we just wanted to say a few things
um
just like my dad was Avid fisherman he
loved his family
and he also loved his Forest he
reads red
ladies and gentlemen we're now here from
Barnaby's family
thank you
good evening
this here okay thank you be really tough
with this so I'm going to give it
another Charlie
um
is seven pages long but I wrote big and
I'll talk fast
Barnaby Philip John Weber was born on
the 11th of January in 2004.
and I want you to know that because he
is more than a victim of a senseless
murder
he loved pesto pasta but he hated
cottage pie
he was obsessed with airplanes and he
still carried a dream of being a pilot
in the RAF one day
I'm not sure really how A History degree
from Nottingham was part of that plan
but but perhaps he wanted to fly
Spitfires
it's been away from his younger brother
Charlie
who despite being three years and eight
months younger than him is considerably
taller as you can see Barnaby pretended
to be cool with this but right Rory
he really wasn't he hated it
that said despite the ribbing the play
fighting the occasional competitive
nurse and far too many swear words
Barnaby he so adored you and he was so
so proud of you
Nottingham
um he really loved you
like he really really loved you and
yesterday and David said we couldn't
bloody get him home half the time
when he was accepted on his place to
study here in only August of last year
he was so bloody chuffed
he loved reading history
but I think actually he loved being part
of the cricket team or
to his teammates I can see you
we thank you for all you have done to
remember him already and I know you have
so much more planned
oh his his shirt number was was 56 by
the way
so today we stand here and we feel your
love and we're United in grief and shock
and disbelief
and one day we will smile again but it
will take time
and we took time this morning Dave
Charlie
some of the tributes that were left up
at the University of Nottingham and
there was one letter that I have to make
mention to it was double-sided big sheet
of A4
written really beautifully by an
individual I don't know if it was
um a male or a female but this person it
was an outpouring of love and support
and confusion and anger angry and this
said in this letter I don't know what to
do I have to write this because I have
no friends
I have no one to talk to but if you want
to come and talk to me I was waiting on
the Terrace and I didn't read that until
this morning but if you get this message
from me then I feel your love and you do
have friends you have friends in us okay
um
thank you thank you thank you
it's not my place to talk about the
other victims Ian and Grace but do know
that we as a family are really grieving
for you as well
the Monstrous
individual who has shattered I will not
Define us and I know he will receive the
retribution that he deserves however
this evil person is just that he is just
a person please hold no hate that
relates to any color sex or religion
and so
[Applause]
my beautiful beautiful boy you have mine
your dad and your brother's heart
forever
Bonnie
as Phoebe says
I know silence is the traditional sign
to show respect and we've had that
tonight but as I finish and you so
kindly walk on this
for you to do one one more thing to show
us an enormous
Round of Applause for everyone affected
by this strategy
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
hello Nottingham
thank you for being here thank you for
showing your love for our babies
be patient with us we we all want to say
a little something
but what I want to say
is that my beautiful baby girl she
wasn't just beautiful on the outside you
must have seen her pictures across media
she was so beautiful on the inside she
was a treasured and adored child
she wanted very few things in life
she wanted to be a doctor
she wanted hockey with her Pals
she wanted to have fun
because that's what all students want
they want to enjoy themselves
and all they were doing was walking home
they were just walking home after a
night out
and like Emma says Emma Weber says
this person must face Justice
it just it just is truly so unfair
but I'll Echo what my husband said
yesterday be kind to each other look
after each other don't have Hate in Your
Hearts
say prayers for my baby girl
I can't say anymore but she did love
Nottingham
I will say one more thing just one more
thing Grace Grace love Nottingham but
she's not from Nottingham and Barnaby
love Nottingham but he's not from
Nottingham either we're from different
parts of the UK Grace from the southeast
greater London and Barnaby from from the
south
from Somerset Taunton
and there's a huge huge community stand
there also needing help there's their
friends their families so it's not
just Nottingham grieving but the the
magnitude of the grief reflects the
magnitude of the love
the love we had for her thank you
[Applause]
as Grace's younger brother
I just want to thank everyone here for
coming to remember
the Lost lives of our loved ones Barney
Grace and Ian and my family especially
from flying over means the most
Grace wasn't only just a sister to me
she was a best friend of mine my mother
my father all her friends
and all her family
and if there's only one message that
comes out of this
I urge you all to cherish every moment
you spend of your loved ones as you just
never know who I know and thank you
foreign
I really mean I really mean it when I
say thank you for taking times out of
your busy lives to be here
and share some grief with us that really
is powerful
and I really thank literally each and
every one of you who's taken the time
thank you so much means so much
we
were full and we allowed three
and and the same
for Barney's family
and they're also they were a four and
they are now three
I speak to as a brokenhearted father
I love my grace
more than I loved anything
and I'm trying to be as strong as I can
forgive me
um
there are people in hospital as well
who injured from this attack and as
families I thought with them as well I
really hope
and wish there must be the recovery
I'd like
I'd like to thank
the uniform services who who always do
such a great job
thank you to the police thank you to the
emergency services thank you for
everyone who did so much
and that Gap that I had in my life that
was Grace
she did love Nottingham when I asked her
to come down home last week she said
a few more sessions as I said yesterday
she loved going out in the old town she
absolutely adored her friends and family
this is one brilliant University Town
and this is a great University that she
went to
she had so many 70 good friends and such
great memories she was so looking
forward to coming back for her second
year
and she would have been a junior doctor
serving you
and your lovely city in the hospital
here
and that's been taken away from us
but thank you so much for being here and
everyone who is doing so much for us in
the background I thank everyone who's
doing that thank you so much and thank
you
the absolute thing I'm going to say
is honestly imagine a world of just love
and no violence
just imagine that world
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen before we close
this evening with some music from
students from the University of
Nottingham I'm going to invite counselor
Sajid Mohammed our portfolio holder for
communities
foreign
I think we still need a couple
of seconds to absorb the words family
if anyone has ever loved
then they would have been moved
by the words
of the families
Nottingham's love has been ignited
by the lives of ear Grace and Barnaby
we came here tonight
to grieve and mourn but we have also
come tonight
to give gratitude and thanks for their
lives
in these dark days for both families
and for this city
it is the light of your courage
and their lives
that has led to Unity
and has led to love
I want to reassure everyone
that
the light and hope and service
of Ian
Grace and Barnaby
is in everyone's heart and will be in
the actions
of this city
their light
a Love and Hope
will be the principle
guidelines for this city to transform
and keep transforming for a city where
everyone can Thrive a city where
everyone can be their best a city where
everyone can be proud of who they are a
city of love a city that is together
I want to reassure the families and this
city
that the light of their love hope and
service is embedded in every police
officer NHS worker
into the city council and into the very
heart of Nottingham and it is this light
and this commitment will keep Nottingham
safe going forward in the next weeks and
months
it is their Light Of Hope and service
that will unify us
whether we're black or white faithful no
faith gay or straight disabled or abled
or young and old We Are One Nottingham
We Are One family and this is our hope
I want to reassure
the families and everyone in this city
that's the light of love and hope their
lives
of love compassion and understanding
will heal this city and make it bigger
and stronger
I just want to end
by thanking everyone
Nottingham is one city one family
Nottingham is together everyone has
their place everyone has their role
everyone
can contribute to this city
in these moments we need to reach out to
our neighbors
to talk to a stranger at the bus stop or
on the tram to have those conversations
at the kettle or the water tower and
just reassure everyone
that this city will stand together
[Applause]
in Grace and Barnaby
let Angels Take Flight and sing thee to
rest thank you
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen thank you so much
for coming today we're now going to
close the event with some music from
students from the University of
Nottingham thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
tell me
where is
[Music]
my God
for these years
[Music]
there's always
[Laughter]
[Music]
rise up follow me
Come Away
[Music]
rise up
follow me
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
event in terms of support and tribute to
the families
please have a safe trip home thank you
[Applause]
well there we are a student choir ending
another a very emotional vigil in
Nottingham this one in Nottingham City
Center last night it was at the
University this one more people from
across Nottingham could come and mourn
those who died in these arcs are awful
attacks on on Tuesday and once again
we heard from members of the families of
those killed we also heard from Civic
leaders from church leaders
and uh but it was the speeches of the
families that were
gut wrenching and extraordinary and we
heard from the family of Ian Coates for
the first time and they thanked everyone
for
for support and for messages
um and they said that uh
their father was an avid
fishermen just let's just have a listen
to uh what his sons had to say it feels
like he's touched a lot of Hearts over
the years more than what we assumed and
knew that he had so it's been really
nice and heartwarming to see the
messages and the people come out and
talk about how I was when they were
younger and how he's helped them
um some beautiful comments
um
we just wanted to say a quick thing that
we're still dealing with what's happened
we still haven't took it all in and so
we just wanted to say a few things
um
just like my dad was an avid fisherman
he loved his family
and he also loved his Forest you read
and then the mother of
Barnaby Weber Emma Weber also came up to
the microphone and she said that he was
more than a victim of a senseless murder
he wanted to be an RAF pilot she said
and he had been torn away from the
family torn away from his brother
Charlie
um
he's she said Nottingham he really loved
you he loved reading history but he
loved being part of the cricket team
more and I think we can have a listen to
what uh Emma Weber had to say
so today we stand here and we feel your
love and we're United in
disbelief
and one day we will smile again but it
will take time
and she also spoke of the man the
suspect who is being held by police and
she said this monstrous individual
this evil person she said will not
Define us
and then she added at the end but please
do not hold hate
um because of color sex or religion and
when she said that there was there was
Applause that was Emma Weber Barnaby's
mother and then the family of Grace
uh came up to speak uh her mother began
Sinead O'Malley and I think
we can have a listen to what she had to
say I'm sorry I'm sorry we can listen
first of all to what her father Dr
Sanjay uh Kumar had to say
we
were at four yeah those three
and and the same
is family
they're also they were a four and then
I'm three
speeches of brokenhearted father
I love my grace
and that was uh
um the father Dr sanjoy Kumar
um speaking there and then we also heard
from
um Grace's younger brother James who
said that Grace was not just a sister
she was a best friend I urge you all to
cherish every moment with your loved
ones because you never know when it will
end
and we also as I was saying heard from
uh Grace's mother
um Sinead O'Malley who said I just want
to say my beautiful baby girl was a
treasure
she wanted very few things in life she
wanted to be a doctor
and she wanted to have fun and then she
said and she was just walking home
and then she said please say prayers for
my baby girl
so the families once again are
contributing to the vigils that are
being held in Nottingham in uh in a very
emotional way a Becky Cottrell is with
me here and uh well it's just been
another hugely emotional uh moment yeah
it was just so raw I mean you and I both
listening to it we're tearing it up I
mean these families must still be in
shock and we're just watching their
grief play out I think it's remarkable
that they can be so eloquent talking
about this and paying tribute to their
loved ones at a time like this and I
felt particularly mood looking at the
younger brothers of Grace and Barnaby
James Grace's brother spoke Charlie
Barnaby's brother didn't but he was
stood there holding what looked like a
school picture of Barnaby and he was
just crying throughout his mother's
speech it's just I mean it's hard to get
your head around
yeah
um right what about the investigation
where are we on the investigation so the
police have got 36 more hours to
question the suspect they will of course
be trying to work out what the motive
for this was counterterrorism police are
helping with the investigation but
police are keeping an open mind
particularly looking into the mental
health of the suspect we've also learned
today that the suspect uh was a former
student at the University of Nottingham
but it's not believed that that fact is
related to the attack and the university
actually said they were devastated to to
learn about this they are mourning to
students but also now learning that a
former student could have been
responsible
um Nottinghamshire police have also
referred themselves to the police
Watchdog after revealing that officers
in a marked car were following the van
that the suspect was in at one point he
hijacked that one from Ian Coates after
stabbing him so the police now refer
themselves to the Watchdog over that
fact right and the Home Secretary was uh
the Home Secretary was visiting uh
Nottingham today
um to pay her respects and to thank the
Emergency Services
yeah and she'll be getting an update as
well on the investigation you can see
her there in those pictures uh laying a
wreath there along with all of the other
flowers it is right that she should have
gone there today and as you say she will
be thanking uh the First Responders who
are on the scene
and she that made the point that the
police still have an open mind about all
this yeah exactly and and we were
discussing earlier that you know by this
point in circumstances like this it
might be starting to be clear what was
behind this attack but it just seems so
senseless So Random students walking on
their way home from a night out Ian
Coates on his way to work
why did this happen and the family is
now talking there I was just thinking
you know these were people going about
their everyday lives and now they're
standing in front of a crowd having to
talk about their children their father
um having been killed it is just so
senseless
yeah and Emma uh Weber Barnaby's mother
making this point at the end of her
um speech at the vigil please do not
hold hate because of color sex or
religion again as you mentioned that got
a big uh Applause you know I think for
the families they will want the focus to
be on remembering their lost loved ones
they will not want anything to be seized
upon uh anything to be misconstrued not
to say of course that she herself isn't
isn't filled with hatred and anger right
now as you mentioned talking about the
suspect describing them as an evil
individual but saying as well that his
actions will not Define this situation
will not Define them
okay Becky thank you very much so uh
we've had the second vigil in two days
and uh we're just seeing there or you
just saw there the families making their
way out of the uh
City Center Square and it is just
impossible to imagine how they are
feeling uh
that is it from the NewsHour and uh
there will be much more
the top of the hour